serious issues that matter contains this
morning with a closer look at climate
change from a Vice President Al Gore has
spent decades working on this global
problem you want a Nobel Peace Prize for
his work he has made two movies on the
subject and Inconvenient Truth in 2006
and this year's An Inconvenient sequel
truth to power I'll tell you where some
of that water's going it's going into
the streets of Miami Beach Florida
but it's not very effective and what
happened new high tide the Cape Denison
so it's gonna get worse at work al gore
is here with us Institute of 5007 we're
pleased to have him welcome thank you
very much so tell me in 10 years what
has changed that alarms you well there
been two big changes Charlie in the last
decade number one the climate-related
extreme weather events have become way
more serious way more common superstorm
sandy here flooded the war memorial 9/11
site for example we have these rain
bombs all over the country all over the
world seven inches in a couple hours in
Florida yesterday the second big change
is that the solutions are here now the
price of electricity from solar and wind
has come down so quickly it's now
cheaper than electricity from fossil
fuels in many parts of the world and
soon almost everywhere and and is there
a will reflected by the Paris Accord by
governments around the world to do
something definitely that was truly an
historic breakthrough virtually every
nation in the world agreed to get the
net zero global warming pollution by
mid-century or soon thereafter as
possible it's in a powerful signal to
markets investors businesses industries
and even though Donald Trump announced
that he was going to pull out of the
Paris agreement the very next day the
entire rest of the world double down on
their commitment and here governors and
mayors and business like Mayor Bloomberg
for me I'm there near Bloomberg did a
great job learning lemon and Governor
Cuomo here in New York and it now looks
as if the US has an excellent chance to
meet our commitments under the Paris
agreement regardless of President Trump
so your worst fears may not happen well
we need with all the commitments in
Paris put together it's still not enough
but it lays a very strong foundation
upon which to build stronger action so
the world would benefit from US
leadership but President Trump is in on
the other side of that unfortunately I
really thought there was a chance he
would come to his senses on it but I was
wrong about that now the pentagon is
called climate change urgent and growing
threat to national security specifically
citing refugee flows on this national
security
Thieme do you think there's a sort of a
foothold for you to have a message that
can persuade President Trump or persuade
those who are so skeptical still about
the science here
well the Pentagon for the for a long
time through several administrations has
said yes this is a national security
issue and they've warned of refugee
flows destabilizing areas like Europe
from the Middle East and North Africa
some regions are in danger of becoming
literally unlivable with the increase in
temperatures and humidity humidity
Worldwide's gone up five percent just in
the last thirty years because of all the
evaporation off the oceans and the
desert of vacation and extended droughts
in the eastern Mediterranean is linked
by the scientists to the multi-sided
civil war in Syria other causes as well
but long before that civil war started
this climate related drought destroyed
60% of their farms killed 80% of their
livestock drove one and a half million
refugees into the cities and the Syrian
ministers were saying on Wikileaks this
is going to cause an explosion we can't
handle this and that was before the
gates of Hell opened in Syria Frances
president has issued an invitation to
American climate scientists to come and
work there and and he phrased it as in
some ways a hit against president Trump
saying you're not welcome to your own
country come to mind I mean is this just
political or is there something that is
truly underway in France in terms of
fighting what you're talking about well
president McCrone of France has done an
outstanding job and his predecessor did
as well in organizing that Paris
conference but not only in France but
all around the world we're seeing an
illustration of the old maxim for every
action there's an equal and opposite
reaction the reaction to what Donald
Trump is doing has been very strong
there is a huge upsurge and activism to
try to solve the climate crisis listen
this is for real I mean our kids are
depending upon us we're feeling the
effects of it now we got to get over
this you know phony kind of discussion
is it real of course it's real the
scientists have been nearly unanimous
for a long time but now Mother Nature is
weighing in turns out she's a way more
persuasive than any of us mr. vice
president I want to drill down on this
threat
to national security many of the
countries who list climate range as a
number-one threat are in Latin America
and Africa leaked that for us the threat
to national security and climate change
in some of these other countries well
it's not only the refugees that are
driven by sea level rise and and
droughts and the extreme weather events
it's also pandemic diseases in Latin
America last year for the first time
ever doctors were telling women don't
get pregnant for two years in some
regions of Central and South America
because of the Zika virus
these mosquitoes bite more often when
the weather goes up they reproduce more
actively that virus incubates more
quickly in the mosquito there's a whole
series of tropical diseases moving into
regions that where you don't have the
immunities that have been developed over
the over the Eon over the centuries and
it's related to the shift of climate
pens to travel revolution and air travel
has had something to do with it for sure
but the climate shifts have changed the
regions where these viruses and and
other microbial diseases are taking hold
and it's it's also a threat to food
security and water scarcity so what is
it that drives the opposition you
believe well I think first of all in
Tennessee there's an old saying if you
see a turtle on top of a fence post you
can be pretty sure it didn't get there
by itself right these persistent levels
of denial unique in the United States
have been intentionally created by the
large carbon polluters taking the
PlayBook from the tobacco companies
hiring pseudo scientists and put out
false data and there all of us as human
beings are resistant to thinking about
something that's hard to think about so
they've got something to work with there
if they can put out some false doubt a
lot of people are go okay we don't have
to worry about this now but we do
because it's here now and if in fact the
EPA has people who have been opposed to
the EPA yeah yeah running it yeah yeah
it's it's horrible the president
surrounded himself with a rogue's
gallery of climate deniers coming out of
the close ties with the carbon polluters
they just ruled a more mercury and
poison into the drinking and I mean it
has some political play in America
I mean President Trump won the election
yeah but not on this issue a plurality
of Trump supporters a majority of
Republican supporters two-thirds of the
American people want to see us stay in
the Paris agreement look our democracy
has been hacked Charlie even before
Putin hacked it by big money and the
carbon polluters have used their
lobbying power and their campaign
contributions playing with these
redistricting areas where all they have
to worry about is a more extreme version
of themselves and so the carbon
polluters have really taken control of
some parts of our democracy we need to
take it back and this upsurge of
activism is is really encouraging we're
working with the indivisible movement
with the launch of this movie this
weekend an inconvenient sequel truth to
power opens on Friday and indivisible
and the climate reality project and
other sierra club going to be all over
the country with other groups trying to
build the momentum to get popular
support to overcome the lobbyists and
the carbon polluters thank you so much
mister I present thank you for having me
thank you for covering issues that
matter thank you thank you sir